okay so she-hulk episode 2 is now out
and though the entry is pretty short
it's filled with a lot of easter eggs
call backs to the comics and also
certain things that tease big storylines
for the future throughout this video
we're going to be breaking it all down
but please hulk smash that thumbs up
button and also don't forget to
subscribe for videos like this every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into she-hulk episode
2.
[Music]
now the episode picks up with a news
report by kpvk 15. this new station has
popped up in the mc before and they're
the channel that reported on giant man
in san francisco bay here they're
reporting on super influencer titania
after her fight with she hulk in court
last week we've kind of gone to the next
level in the mcu with superheroes now
becoming celebrities and titania is
basically a superstar that has
superpowers rather than actually being a
hero when we go to news los angeles we
get a comment from titania's lawyer that
says the entire thing was the result of
low blood sugar i asked the wife if this
was in relation to anything and she told
me kim kardashian did a low sugar diet
that caused a bit of controversy so
so there's your wife's easter eggs now
kzyo also dropped their thoughts too and
throughout we see they use animated
images of the courtroom fight this is
done in the style of a court sketch and
it's also the same way that the credits
are presented to you now we actually get
one of those credit scenes play out with
jennifer going to her families for
dinner this was presented to us last
week and on top of that we can also see
jen lifting up a cabinet so that her
mother can hoover underneath it this
calls back to the comics and she
actually did the same thing with jarvis
when he was cleaning the avengers
mansion and from here we cut to an
eyewitness report
light like a chickahawk
a she-hulk
exactly this is a nice little nut to
last week namely when bruce was talking
about names and how it's normally the
public that give them rather than people
choosing them for themselves go to the
legal bar and growl and we see that jen
isn't too happy about the new name it's
sort of like when i changed from
definition to heavy spoilers or when i
brought poor jared across and everyone
started calling him a dead in the
comments but he's a nice guy yeah
he'll grow on you probably don't
unsubscribe are they do some meta
commentary on how lots of spin-off
characters get similar names like ms
marvel though she is pretty cool so you
can stay and they also bring up
superhero stereotypes six figures in
student loans to become a vigilante that
is for billionaires and narcissists and
adult orphans for some reason now
there's lots of heroes that fit this
mold with iron man being the standout
the line itself could also be a call
back to the avengers when tony said this
to cap take that off what are you genius
billionaire playboy philanthropist
they also bring up whether the avengers
are even paid or not which was something
that links back to when falcon tried to
take out a bank loan now obviously
there's that guy who wanted to take over
her speech last week and he comes in
demanding to know how she got her powers
they do this line that i don't know if
it's genius or the most on the nose men
or bad thing that i've ever heard but i
did chuckle a bit
there's a hot chick over there i'm gonna
go talk to it gotta go talk to it
me but we're moving on now over this we
hear this song never stop this flame by
celeste which my uk heads will probably
be sick of hearing if they've ever
watched epl on sky sports now last week
we guessed that they'd follow the comics
and fire hair for having the potential
to influence a jury they have this scene
here and it calls back to not only dance
slots run but also sensational she-hulk
in the former she had to pause her
closing statement to go and save the
world with the avengers and the next day
she was called in by her boss and fired
for her mistrial potential this was
carried out by the character blake tower
who looks exactly the same in the source
material as he does here in sensational
she-hulk issue 10 jen saved several jury
members and thus they called for a
mistrial now when she transforms back
into her normal self she collapses due
to the amount of alcohol in her system
this too happens in the comics during
the boss scene however they do change
things up slightly for the show whilst
she's getting fired here the source
material had holden holloway going to
hire her and then she collapsed in front
of him after taking the job this does
get played upon later but i thought i'd
just bring it up here as well to show
how they sort of differentiate now she
hulk is all about becoming your best
self and that's why we've teamed up with
manscape to bring you their platinum
package 4.0 it's the biggest bundle i've
ever offered and it comes with the
lawnmower 4.0 the weedwacker era nose
trimmer the ultra premium body wash
ultra premium two in one shampoo and
conditioner ultra premium deodorant crop
preserver anti-chafing ball deodorant
prop reviver ball toner spray
anti-shaving boxer briefs and the shed
travel bag to keep your kids safe like i
said massive giveaway and inside it
you'll find the lawnmower 4.0 which has
ceramic blades that make it the safest
shave ever it's got advanced skin safe
technology and you will marvel at the
way it stops you from getting nicks and
cuts added is that it's also waterproof
and it comes with a spotlight on the
front to help you shave in the dark now
the kit also comes with the weed whacker
which is by far the best ear and nose
trimmer that i've ever used i've been
using manscape for about a year now and
it always gets the job done quickly and
i absolutely love this piece now in
addition to all this you can upgrade
your shower routine with the ultra
premium body wash and also the ultra
premium shampoo conditioner it's two in
one puts together the best of both
worlds like the smart hulk and it will
keep you mean green and clean maybe not
green but it'll definitely keep you
clean after you've given yourself the
perfect haircut you can also use the
crop preserver ball deodorant spray that
will keep your abomination nice and
fresh
it's got a soothing aloe vera formula
and it's the best in the business when
it comes to keeping you dry and also
smelling great manscaped have also
included two free gifts this includes
the anti-chafing box of briefs that will
make sure your hulk never gets a rash
and this shed travel bag so you can take
your kit protect it wherever you want to
go mexico the lot go to manscape.com and
enter the code heavy spoilers at
checkout to get 20
off and also free shipping that's
manscape.com heavy spoilers at checkout
20 off and free shipping manscape.com
heavy spoilers 20 off free shipping i'll
see you over there cheers now after
she's let go she's unable to get a job
because she's seen as a liability and we
watch as she's fallen on hard times she
gets a voicemail from her cousin bruce
and rejection after rejection one thing
i love here is that the offices get
worse and worse and worse and she goes
from a swanky one all the way through to
a crappy law firm cementing how
desperate she is we cut back to her home
and sees several takeaway boxes and also
lots of open bottles of wine in the
comics jen drank quite a lot and was
always out partying and along with her
getting fired from her job she was also
kicked out of adventures mansion now on
jen's laptop there's some really really
big easter eggs we firstly see up top
that there are some iron man 3 sneakers
which are based on jordans and air force
ones next though is what could
potentially be a reference to wolverine
as we saw from the end of ms marvel
mutants are coming to the mcu and this
could be a little hint towards weapon x
the headline reads man fights with metal
claws in bar brawl potentially hinting
to logan popping up very soon the one
below that says why there is a giant
statue of a man sticking out of the
ocean i think that this is the first
reference in the mcu to the ending of
the eternals which so far hasn't really
been acknowledged jen's locked screen is
captain america's ass and this calls
back to not only the post-credits scene
of last week but also ant-man saying
america's ass in endgame also i know
you're probably screaming at the screen
right now there's a qr code there it's a
qr code there yeah scan that you get
yourself another free she-hulk comic i'm
always saving you money you son of a
[ __ ]
now along the top we can also see stuff
like find ant-man which is probably
referencing how scott lang has become a
bit of a celebrity ms marvel showed us
that he now had a podcast and the
quantomania trailer had him at a book
reading where we discovered he'd become
a celeb could also just be like where's
wally or where's waldo thing if you're
in the u.s now there's also a norse
mythology tab as well as an avengers one
too she visits her family and her dad
asks her if hawkeye collects his arrows
which i think kate bishop also did in
that disney plus series it's a bit of an
awkward meal with them just constantly
asking her questions that suggests she
hasn't got her life together her dad
seems to genuinely care though and in
the comics he was a county sheriff who
ended up dying in a car accident yeah
though they changed things up so she has
a bit more of a family relationship and
with her cousin bruce being in it too
it's all about family now this series is
very much taking a lot of inspiration
from ali mcbeal this comes across in its
fourth wall breaking moments the humor
and also the general procedural style
built around a female protagonist we get
a little nod to this when january visits
the bar and we can catch the show
playing on the tv this is where holden
comes in to hire her calling back to the
comics she's recruited to work at glkh a
logo of which looks similar to the
original way that they had the she-hulk
logo before it changed up now the name
glkh is a reference to several marvel
creators the g is for marvel publisher
martin goodman the l is for libre as in
stanley's original surname kurtzberg is
a reference to jack kirby's original
name and holloway well that's not a
reference to anything but he's the only
partner that we actually meet the comics
actually have holloway harboring a dark
secret that i don't want to spoil just
yet in case they go that way however
there's a specific reason that he's
hired jen to protect superhumans which
we might get a reveal too later down the
line we get to monday and see her
heading into work she's greeted by
holden and given a tour of the building
in the comics a similar scene happened
but it was revealed that holden was
actually a shape-shifter called ditto
who was just masquerading as her boss
that's not a spoiler by the way he just
takes jen up to the office where she
meets the real holden that's not the
dark secret yet i haven't ruined that
promise either way he tells her that he
wants her to be the head of the
superhuman division which is the
position she also gets in the comics i
think every week she'll probably just be
dealing with a different case with next
week's probably being the abomination
before we head into the other ones how
he wants her to appear as the she-hulk
and chord but this is the opposite of
the comics whereas she hates going as
her on the show the source material had
her not really wanting to turn back to
jen because she couldn't accept who she
really was she's turned into a spectacle
and we even see the receptionist taking
a quick photo as she passes by anyway
it's your favorite part of the show it's
definitely your favorite part of the
show isn't it it's jared's easter eggs
[Music]
now at this point we see her pass a
co-worker who behind him has a cabinet
full of comic book covers this pulls
directly from the dan slot run of comics
where jen
can i call you jen
she herself is walking through the law
firm meets with a co-worker and behind
him has a collection of his own well
guess what these heroes were sellout
chumps and licensed their likeness to
these comic book companies to make a
little bit more money on the side
obviously she hulk has done this herself
but then we also see famous covers from
other heroes such as thor hulk captain
marvel and captain america the last of
which calls back to the first avenger
where in this movie we see an
in-universe comic for the character
based on the comics that were sold
during the second world war they've
obviously removed bucky from the cover
because the mcu version went a slightly
different path and honestly they don't
even look the same i mean look at them
not even close really nice that they
inserted this callback to the comics
itself showing that the comics
exist in the non-come
what day is oh my gosh my head where's
the tylenol get out you're fired again
now jen doesn't seem too enthusiastic
about it but she's got a corner office
her mate nicki works as a paralegal and
we meet pog he's based on the character
augustus pogliezi who worked at the law
firm with her in the comics he's played
by josh seguerra who you might recognize
from arrow and i'm expecting him to make
a bigger impact in the show at some
point pog was a love interest for jen so
i can see this sort of developing as we
get further into the series anyway her
first case is emil blonsky aka the
abomination one of the first villains in
the mcu he's had a change of heart and a
maybe he's changed now he's being held
in the damage controlled supermax prison
that we first saw in ms marvel though
this hasn't been given a specific name
it looks extremely similar to the cube
from the comics this too was a super max
prison designed to hold superhumans and
it's also the same place that we saw
wang and abomination going into in
chongqi we'll talk about this more later
on but it's clear that this is happening
alongside that film with a fight scene
being something that's brought up at the
end of the entry whereas she wasn't
allowed to be in gen form in the office
here she's told the opposite he's taken
through a red laser grid which she
nervously steps through and this could
be a callback to episode 1. in that hulk
melted down her blood sample using the
same sort of lasers so it explains why
she's so nervous here there's lots of
silence of the lamb's references with
the gods leading her down whilst
explaining all the rules jen even jokes
about some fava beans and a nice chianti
which is of course a call back to that
movie and hannibal lecter's infamous
prison scene
however emile is perfectly charming and
pretty different to how he was in the
incredible hulk tim roth has always been
a great actor with good comedic timing
but they never really leaned into that
in the incredible hulk however here they
play it up and also talk about emile's
lineage at the time of the first movie
there was a lot of talk about how they
changed dimmer because he was croatian
and yugoslavian in the comics however
yugoslavia no longer exists and also
with roth being british they just
changed it up now he was a royal marines
commando on loan to the american army
and he was put in place to take banner
out he genuinely feels regret over
attacking bruce and the hulk and to be
honest the guy he's kinda got a bad rap
hulk destroyed a lot of cities and he
was also seen as a monster but he became
a hero after the battle of new york emil
though never really got that chance and
he's been in jail since he even wrote
bruce a lovely and thoughtful letter
apologizing for how he acted and hey i
believe in second chances bring jared
back go on bring him back even even if
he's the worst part of the videos i
can't stay mad at him now speaking of
the worst part of the video it's on to
theory time
so emil clearly believes that he could
have been a hero and this is cemented by
this line i thought i was gonna be you
know
captain bloody america something he
thought he could become like captain
america and you know who else this is
like john walker now he was recruited by
val and i believe that a similar thing
will happen with abomination where he's
drafted into the u.s special forces in
order to pay for his crimes we know from
the marvel slate announcement at
comic-con that there's a thunderbolts
movie on the way and this will likely
feature people like john walker zemo and
abomination now in case you don't know
the thunderbolts are basically marvel
sansa to the suicide squad and these are
reformed villains that end up trying to
do good in order to right the wrongs of
the past with abominations case coming
up next week i think that jen might even
put forth the idea that he does a sort
of community service thing and that he
uses his powers for good he could end up
being drafted into the thunderbolts and
this would be a way for him to win back
his freedom he's clearly changed and he
might even be a big help in the rumored
upcoming world war hulk film that we'll
talk about later on in the video anyway
that's in it dear time
[Music]
now you might also notice that there are
red lasers around the cell and tying
back to the ones from earlier these
might actually be capable of killing
hulks would explain how it was able to
destroy her blood last week and also why
it's here might also just hurt someone
with powers but i'm guessing we'll
probably see the explanation for this in
a future episode jen learns that the
serum given to him caused the
abomination to be created but
technically it was the homie the leader
who gave him the final dose that ended
up transforming him either way jen
season in here with emil being used as a
patsy to cover for the government you
also find out that he's got seven soul
mates who brought in property and this
is clearly poking fun at people who end
up falling in love with prisoners no one
ever falls in love with me but it gives
jen some hope that she can help him out
however she wants to double check with
bruce and we discover he's actually on
the secarian courier ship that we saw
last week now once more this is clearly
setting things up for a world war hulk
storyline that book centered around hulk
riving on sakhar and here he was
enslaved as a gladiator hulk ended up
creating a rebellion and he overthrew
the ruler of the planet to supplant
himself he married a warrior that was
once part of the emperor's forces and
she fell pregnant however the ship he
was sent in exploded and this killed her
along with a large number of his people
he returned to earth as part of the
world war hulk storyline and he went to
war with all the marvel heroes it's an
incredible burk packed with outstanding
action scenes and if they do end up
adapting this then it could be a major
thing for the hulk i know a lot of
people are kind of meh on how he's been
neutered and this storyline would allow
him to go back to being a monster now
hulk eventually discovered that his son
survived this and he became the
character score this could be a way to
take hulk in the future with him
becoming a father figure and thus
getting a more ruley hulk to follow in
case you don't know the rights to the
hulk have been tied up with universal
for decades now and the only way marvel
get to use him in movies is through
having him guest star that's why he's
always in things like the avengers
ragnarok and shows like this they can
use him as long as he's not the main
character which is why the incredible
hulk is produced by universal i think
those rights actually come to an end
next year and this would give them the
opportunity to start world war hulk
introduce his son let mark ruffalo bow
out and follow the characters that he
helped set up you might not quit i don't
know it's all legal issues really that i
don't know that much about so pretty
useless information there but uh jen
accepts the job and she says she has a
strategy but this all goes to hell when
we see the fight scene from chongqi now
i think that the next episode will
probably center around jen trying to see
if she can have this excuse but i don't
know if the government will be too happy
about it he's clearly been sneaking out
a lot and i think rather than getting
his freedom he'll be forced to work it
off in the thunderbolts i'm also
guessing that next week we'll have the
one cameo that we saw in the teasers as
he's of course gonna have to explain
what's going on he might go as a
character witness to someone to help
show a meal has changed i think jen will
probably be mad that he said he doesn't
turn into the abomination anymore but
she's still gonna defend him it would be
one of her not to and this keeps things
in line with the comics as we did have
sores for us visiting the law firm
however in the source material it was
doctor strange instead of wong however
wang is the sorcerer supreme at the
moment so that makes more sense the post
credit scene is jen basically doing all
the heavy lifting jobs at their families
and this includes holding up a car
putting a flat screen on the wall and
carrying in some water a huge shout out
to you guys for pointing out some easter
eggs on our last video this included
that the final scene was a reference to
the trial of the incredible hulk i think
ryanairy pointed it out on his video but
i'm not never i'll never give him credit
or acknowledge that he even exists he's
so he's the worst youtuber ever shut the
[ __ ] up ryanairy doug's alright though
there was also bruce's helmet from
sakaar hanging up in the little mexico
getaway now as for our thoughts on the
episode again i thought this was okay
but it's still not something that has
massively won me round
yes kevin spoilers has turned into the
very thing he saw to destroy some dead
who just moans about everything i'm
saying it's okay though i'm not saying
it's terrible but i don't think it's
amazing either i think it just for me
personally it just kind of sits in that
mid-range bracket my because i'm a man
as many of you have pointed out and also
might be because i'm a massive sexist as
you you've correctly you figured it out
if you figured out my agenda the only
reason that i think she hulk might be
okay is because i'm a massive sexist and
i hate women but moving on from that let
me explain exactly why i feel this way
so i actually think that the way that
these shows have been released would
have worked better as a binge the first
episode was pretty much just jen going
through the paces and this one was about
her losing her job and then getting a
new one handed to her on a plate i still
do kind of feel that the show is lacking
any real struggles for her but like many
of you have said that might be the point
because everything just works out for
her we might start to see the real
challenges come from the new job and
that will be what she has to overcome
it's a bit difficult to probably give
fully fleshed out thoughts when we're so
early in but whenever i skip the review
part of videos i always get people
kicking off so you just can't win just
being honest with that and i hope that
this at least shows that i don't say
everything's amazing just because i get
early access i do think the show is
really held up by the performances and
though the writing is okay i want to see
a bit more to really bring this up to
the level of the other superhero shows
that are released this year this episode
also felt really short and it ended at a
weird point there's been this weird two
act structured about episodes with the
first having the origin story and then
the court scene second episode had a
weird structure to it as well where she
lost her job and then decided to take
the one with a new legal law firm really
felt like a two-parter because of this
with a cliffhanger obviously leading
into next week i'm not sure there's
enough here though to really grip me to
that point where i'm desperate to learn
about next time though so doing a part
of this early on
it just feels a bit weird now i think if
the series had been released all at once
and it would have been fine and this
wouldn't have felt so short and weirdly
paced out i know the dance slot run is
great but yeah i just think the series
could have structured it a lot better
now i'd obviously love to hear your
thoughts i'm looking forward to getting
called a shill when i finally say i
actually liked an episode and yeah i'm
sorry for being a negative nancy but
that's just how our bloody feel kevin
feige uh don't blacklist me please now
we are in a competition right now and
giving away three copies of top gun
maverick on the 15th of september and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode you pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so that's you then message me
on twitter at heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of house of
the dragon which will be linked on
screen right now it's a new bloody game
of thrones thing is it going to be good
is it gonna be bad well we'll talk about
it so hopefully i see over there right
after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video peace